[Musique]
salut ça me ferait aujourd'hui vous
allez vous en doutez on va parler de
brossage de dents et on teste une brosse
à dents qui m'a été remise ya pas très
longtemps c'est l'ami électrique tous
bosch la brosse à dents et reaching
quand je les ai eus je me suis dit waouh
petite brosse à dents électrique pendant
le brosser les dents c'est plutôt pas
mal mais au final ça m'a un peu plus
loin et c'est assez intéressant
c'est pour ça que je voulais partager
avec vous parce que hogan est une brosse
à dents électrique
vous avez votre tête que vous pouvez
changer vous rentrez c'est un grand
classique
vous avez trois niveaux effectivement
comme vous brosser les dents ça seul mot
de pain le mode 2 le mode 3 autour du
lac rose à tartines mais surtout ce qui
est intéressant avec ça c'est ce que
vous allez pouvoir brancher avec votre
application me home vous allez le
synchroniser avec votre appli et ça me
filer plein d'infos plein de détails sur
votre temps de brossage alors vous nous
direz quel intérêt d'avoir des sacs aux
frontons brossage pouvoir optimiser sa
n'a au final c'est passé comme ça je
m'en fous l'idée ce n'est pas de devenir
le champion toutes catégories du
brossage ne vous pouvez cas le
personnaliser et sauf que ça ça c'est
intéressant alors dans le coffre
ça c'est ma maison hop électrique tous
brèche qui est la personnalisation vous
avez la protection anti éclaboussures 10
secondes c'est à dire que vous l'allumez
vous l'activez pendant 10 secondes avait
pas partir je vendais dans votre bouche
et là elle part vous caler votre durée
de brossage d'une minute deux minutes 50
le mode de brossage débutants nous
standard performances améliorées et
surtout 30 secondes de blanchimont
supplémentaires 30 secondes pour les
trois de vos gencives 10 secondes pour
les triages dans votre langue envoyé pas
mal de possibilités et ça c'est plutôt
cool vous l'enregistrer elle se
synchronise directement en bluetooth
avec votre brosse à dents ça c'est
plutôt cool aussi pour les réglages et
pour récupérer plein d'infos sur votre
brossage arts vous direz c'est jamais
que des statistiques mais ça peut être
sympa
il ya un côté un peu ludique ça rend les
au brossage de dents petit peu moins
chiant un petit peu moins pénible
le truc qui me rend avec l'application
c'est ça vous fait une espèce de
gamification ça vous donne
des points en fonction de votre brossage
ça vous donne pas mal de statistiques et
au delà de ça c'est vrai qu'à côté un
peu intéressants et vous avez même à la
fin un score brossage le côté technique
c'est un moteur à lévitation magnétique
de haut rendement dans des cas plus
support spécialiste du brossage toujours
est il que vous avez une vibration haute
fréquence de 31 mille fois par minute
autant dire que ça vivre y performent
c'est assez particulier je sais pas si
vous avez eu ce genre de pensée dont un
électrique
j'ai déjà testé mois les brosses à dents
rotatives ça marche ça marche plutôt pas
mal la sensation est vraiment différente
ne doit pas ce que vous avez vraiment
une sensation de vibrations partout dans
votre bouche c'est à la fois marrant à
la fois des fois peu déconcertant il est
assez surprenant mais bon dans l'absolu
ça fait le job et c'est néanmoins salle
plus intéressant je sais pas si ça
paiera tout le monde ce type de
sensations en tout cas en terme de
sensations j'ai vraiment l'impression
que ça fait le job et que ça va vraiment
bien nettoyer les dents vous avez une
batterie de 700 millions perdre
là-dedans shiomi donne une autonomie de
18 jours lorsqu'elle est chargé à fond
vous pouvez l'utiliser 18 jours pour un
brossage quotidien plusieurs fois par
jour sans avoir absolument aucun
problème pour la recharger il suffit de
la brancher en usb ou en prenant un
petit adaptateur secteur du smartphone
vous le premier vous la posez dessus et
sa recharge
vous avez un voyant qu ici sur le côté
qui va vous indiquer le niveau de charge
de batterie et vous avez un indice
d'étanchéité ipx7 voilà pour cette
brosse à dents chahoumi à une vidéo un
peu à part que ce soit aujourd'hui mais
ce produit j'ai eu
l'autre fois à madrid et puis je me suis
dit mon finale pourquoi pas vous la
présenter parce que c'est pas vraiment
intéressant d'ailleurs ciel vous
intéresse je vous ai mis un lien dans la
description au mât aile un tarif très
intéressant sur grève est donc n'hésitez
pas si vous pouvez vous brosser les
dents sans nous endetter petites infos
supplémentaires espèces voit bien là
c'est la brosse à dents regular ici donc
il existe plusieurs types de tête pour
des sur toutes les sensibilités des
gencives soit dur dur et villages où je
pense
ou vous pouvez aussi commander toutes
vos têtes de recharge directement sur le
web et pour ça je vous ai mis tous les
liens également en bas dans la
description là je la remets en place
tout va bien merci à vous d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo dites moi ce que
vous en pensez à ce que vous utilisez
une brosse à dents électrique pour les
trier vos jolies dents est ce qu'une
brosse à dents comme celles de chiots
1000 points vous intéresser qu'est ce
que vous pensez que ce système est ce
que vous trouvez que c'est pertinent pas
pertinent on marque tout sans
commentaire vous invite à rester
connectés parce que y avoir plein
d'autres surprises
ces quelques jours je vais partir en
vacances donc on va un petit peu
ralentir le rythme des vidéos pendant
une dizaine de jours mais continuerait
de vous en faire directement de ça vous
fera voyager avec moi en attendant merci
à vous masquez plus en plus nombreuse
toujours plus nombreux et boudet très
bientôt plus d'un
[Musique]